[Music]
ingenious idea news submitted by push
the button a chef launched a late-night
meal delivery service for strippers nice
about time ah that's high and he comes
in all of them hope I hope it's diet
food so there's so much coming from this
side of the room I hope diet so the
strippers don't get bad no before that
they want that exactly let me let me get
I got your back I got your back good if
there's all options that money listen
Oregon so this shop will they have all
these furs
she's from Portland and so she said she
got this really great idea to start this
a catering service for strippers would
complain about having nowhere healthy to
eat after her shift was over so she
started delivering meals to her friend
at the strip club and then soon other
dancers wanted to get in on after a long
days of twerking yeah I need to have a
salad in my system cuz I try to eat
[ __ ] Burger King at night no it's
only fast-food like just Taco Bell and
like just really unhealthy [ __ ] she's
like I don't wanna be bloated and stuff
like see I knew it any always haters you
don't want strippers to get fat because
that's probably the yeah but I don't
want them to get fat on the one hand but
on the other hand I don't think that
they want to get that either you want to
empower them to not get fat that's
exactly right I think they just want to
be healthy I feel the same way though
cuz when I go on post mates or whatever
like at 12:00 at night or one I'm like
it's just Taco Bell I don't want to talk
about maybe you shouldn't be eating so
late that's what I was thinking but
strippers are working that thing I get
all eight minutes Burnie Cal's dude they
were burning hard cows she's suffering
from insomnia yeah alright so she called
it meals for six and he'll
cute goes on heals that's time so her
name is Nikki she she delivers them on
Hills as well yeah
okay what's on her menu um I don't know
but it's healthy stuff
mmm looks like there's gonna see none it
doesn't like I don't know I love her
it's just it's just for the house yeah
oh it says fueling Portland sex workers
so yeah how you get to that that's kind
of mean
so right now she's actually a woman
believe crackheads he can order so she's
saying that she's a one-woman show she
cooks and delivers each of the 20-plus
orders she gets weekly she is interested
so you pay order yeah it's a cash
business dude I'm sure they got a lot of
cash to that's time
yeah as strippers are rich that's good
for taxi and strippers aren't
necessarily rich they ball in according
to the world like bull poppy rates and
yeah I mean they got money but the
amount of money that they should get
that they don't like at the end of a
shift and you have to tip out like the
bartender and the deejay and all the
things it's insane it's like I'm over
here showing you my [ __ ] like why yeah
it shouldn't be 10% a 10% 10% and 10%
when you walk out with like I heard some
top-notch ones make like 40 grand amount
mm-hmm 40 damn that's very nice so
that's cool so he doesn't say what's on
her menu um let me pull up her what let
me see
in the meantime you guys I love this
this is brilliant
Jess you could uh meal prep and then
you'll have healthy food that's true
that's what I do I already get enough
[ __ ] from people that I don't cook I
don't need to hear it from you oh I was
just making a suggestion because they're
gonna suggest Peter suggestions does
that help out a friend you know just
Victor died and I had to do that yeah
I'll start cooking now now that I'm not
in a really big world relief easy
recipes just now on my tasty Tuesday
video just about but I like to eat meat
you could add me okay you got me to any
of that stuff crazy just saying there
are solutions in this one added chicken
to the quinoa
where are they what I wonder how she
makes sure that it's just you know she
wants to be exclusive just for sex
workers so how does she make sure maybe
depending on what time James will be
delivering like if it's at 4 a.m. cool
well she also it sounds like she makes
20 meals so she probably just delivers
to the strip right it seems like she
knows exactly the girl livers yeah yeah
and she's like okay that's a really
small customer base yeah wonder she only
hands out business cards so like the
only way you can make an order is like
if you have heard her specific she's
looking to expand she said so so now
she's gonna move on to prostitutes Bobby
well she'd have to hire like a sous-chef
or some delivery person or something
like I would hire those people first
before expanding my business okay
there's cam girls too because they
stream late what cameras can stream any
I'll make it also like ordered but it's
all bad food yeah bad food look at me
can i order from this lady why don't you
order at 8:00 p.m.
keep that meal in your fridge or of
course mates even as a webcam girl like
you don't want to get dressed and then
like open the door if you know it's her
and she's cool you could just walk up
there with a dildo in your [ __ ] still
and you open up and you're like thanks
you got to get back to your stream you
know that's really good still stayed
like busy really like this girl can't
take the dildo out of here please
either go into the duchies Marcus
she's on-the-job fantasy well I'm just
okay I'm just thinking they're
hardworking and like sometimes I get too
busy and I'm just like nobody goes in
there it's in I'm not gonna do this why
why I think I totally understand your
point yeah yeah it's a good point I do
that I get bothered when I order post
mates and I have to put clothes on oh my
god it's the worst leave it on the porch
that's that's the smartest idea cuz you
don't want people necessarily to know
where you live what you look like lately
I've been this thought has been entering
my mind that like what if someone knew
where you lived and they wanted to
poison you anyone could poison any post
mates delivery like there should be some
sort of um idea no there should be some
sort of system like with these mates
where it's sealed yeah the people at the
restaurant seal it some people who would
poison you huh like if they found out
where you live your enemies like if
you're a Russian spy or what if it was
just a random person that was like I
think I oh that was jacking off into
like good food no yeah you will I mean
we're when I said this guys try to come
on everybody's food good point we judged
you that that was problematic also this
guy and he had HIV and then people will
eat it and then they got HIV oh that's
good okay well listen the internet here
sucks it does have a website it can't
pull it up nice dari I always thought
about that because like you know I'll
have you born Sami X now but they should
be healthy too yes true just because
they can't sleep doesn't mean especially
be healthy why can't I do a
drive-through of something healthy yeah
hey freakin in Texas has a [ __ ]
drive-through I swear nothing in LA has
a drive-through it's cuz of demand bro
there ain't no demand for divorce yeah
who craves a salad at 3:00 a.m. right
you drive maybe both some people don't
do you I don't drink so maybe that's why
but I think that's what it is though
you're being smart at 3 a.m. and most
people are like I'm drunk I want
something [ __ ] great I think like at
3 a.m. I want a salad during the day I
want pizza and french fries and like a
grilled cheese really
you're the office depends what my
cravings are I see yeah produce can go
bad quickly
maybe that's why and it's expensive yeah
it's all a price point things with
healthy food is expensive I'll show you
the website oh my god sorry editor you
can't I can't get this for you
but just use the screen okay oh it's it
it's vegan right so yeah I mean you
could see the dishes so you wouldn't
like it anyway Jeff through this little
it's vegan
no no she also said there's like chicken
yeah there's all she has these like
funky that I just I feel like it's a
bouquet and I can't eat it
that [ __ ] looks pretty I can yeah it
looks like flowers and it doesn't look
delicious to her website is dope
yeah pretty slick yeah it looks good
though but no I'm not talking about her
food but like whenever I see that kind
of style I'm like what do I do with it
there's like a flower and some grass
I've never seen that like old cuz you
could go to sushi restaurants and get
vegan sushi like avocado rolls miso soup
soy beans like that's a whole meal and
that's vegan but I don't we talk about
some la places have like wheatgrass and
[ __ ] no but the way that it's presented
it's it's it's actually very nice like
its artistic and all that but it's
intimidating to eat it because it's not
food in my head look at it and I'm like
man this just yeah I don't know and I
don't know what I'm gonna taste so like
you know how you have that flavor in
your head or your mouth when you look at
a hamburger you're like I know what
that's gonna taste you're talking about
like pates or some [ __ ] no he's just
talking like food that is extravagantly
presented yeah yeah when there's like
you've got like a little blossom flower
a little some things to launch on the
top it's like yeah I don't know what to
go am I craving this it's like mixture
there's like beans and grass like I
don't know like bees and grass is it
gonna taste like lime I don't know like
dig it and find out yeah but what I'm
looking for food and I'm thinking I hope
you I looked at it and I always skip it
cuz I just don't really this
asses are everything thank you put some
tahini sauce on anything maybe yeah
but if I see a chicken like Caesar salad
I'm like I know what that tastes like
and I'm thinking about it I could eat
that right now yeah what's the word it
doesn't look appetizing at me yeah yeah
it's not maybe you're gonna actually eat
it yeah and then you'll start
registering it and you're like oh I know
what it's like yeah and then now you'll
know that it tastes like stripper food
yep
that's pretty cool this is the same I
love where what's your name
nakisha nakisha Janna Keisha Newton
[Music]